and you've had some huge moments what
was the one moment that you can reflect
on that you felt either the most nervous
or where you really had to like kind of
pinch yourself like [ __ ] this is
actually about to happen or this is
happening you know what man it was
probably the day i got uh
um the best rap album grammy nomination
like that was in and i can't wait to win
them things in the future like you know
nominations are great infinite gratitude
but
i'm going to win them things and who
were you nominated alongside it was me
tyler the creator
oh igor yeah igor won it yep um which
wasn't a rap album i think he should
have won album of the year yes like you
know i'm not i wasn't known but he was
what he said
after those awards is true like yeah
they should they kind of just bunched
them in with hip hop i mean yeah for
sure it wasn't a rap album it was a
great album by the way amazing album
amazing now he should have won album of
the year like for sure
and but i was happy to see him win
because he earned it he's been in the
game for a minute it was his time you
know
um
and i was just like well i just gotta
pay my dues bro like he doesn't pay his
dues he doesn't put out great albums
that didn't get recognized so it was
just his time but i think he should have
won at the highest level which is album
of the year i agree and um
so yeah like um i say all that to say
probably getting nominated for best rap
album
at that i just remember that's the most
like i lived in the moment i was already
on vacation at the time i was in turks
and caicos wow and then i watched like
them announcing the grammy nominations
and
i remember because they said my name
last because they said in alphabetical
order so i heard the first four names
and then i ain't hear my name and it's
all because the ybn yeah exactly and so
by being i was like because i thought i
was like i thought i wouldn't go because
i just knew i was gonna get it for sure
i knew i was gonna get it and then when
they said my name lad my heart sung when
i think my name didn't get called and i
heard it i'm like let's [ __ ] go i
didn't even care about the best rap song
right nomination i just wanted that
album album yeah because that's what
matters
like out bodies of work you want to be
you know people get best rap song and
nominations all the time but best rap
album that's a big deal no for sure
especially up against you know like a
tyler and things of that nature so i was
like
that that was probably the most like i
lived in the moment sort of moment for
me